pas le 21 décembre par contre c'est les
restos du coeur et madame coluche donne
le menu lui or véronique colucci bonsoir
tu l'a connue comment coluche d'entrée
quand il était au café de la gare
soixante dix équipes the cloud qu'est ce
que tu faisais faut que fait de la gare
j'étais spectatrice tous les soirs puis
je venais quand même de faire un petit
article pour combat que jamais passé un
tube ou c'est pour combat et c'est
l'époque du shah piegza
tout allait faire un papier sur coluche
était tombée amoureuse de lui et voilà
j'ai c'est l'état qui est très très
profondément
mais lui n'était pas qu'une fille quand
tu la connais nous on était en rupture
bon ben je me serais pas permis sinon en
rupture de qui domine union ah bon vous
êtes arrivés juste à protéger
voilà un cantonales et alors les enfants
comment ils vont savoir la fille est la
tienne la mienne va très bien me
ressemblent à leurs pères ou non qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent faire attentivement un
grand bien un qui a l'air de se diriger
vers sciences po petite ânesse et il est
né et l'autre c'est plutôt la comédie on
verra pour l'instant si tu peux aller
pousser maintenant quoi je les
pousserait où ils veulent
alors les restos du coeur le principe
c'est quoi au départ le principe c'est
un courrier gigantesque qui parvient à
michel en disant très beau qui remontent
très bien les aider mais en france c'est
la même chose il ya un monde qu'on
ignore
michel qui s'aperçoit qu'en fait cette
situation dépasse tout ce qui peut être
dit dans les statistiques
ceux qui sortent du filet social sont
très nombreux et complètement démunis et
surtout laissé pour compte
le club des gens qui mangent pas voilà
il ya des gens qui mangent pas à côté de
ce top de la cee qui existent et qui
sont en abondance plaint d'une
nourriture qui pourra qui pourrit pas
mais qui est congelé pendant des
dizaines d'années et que une économie
s'est créé là dessus qui est
complètement aberrante
cette saison c'est la cinquième qu'est
ce qu'il va se passer sur deux spéciales
déjà c'est que ce qui est inouïe c'est
de voir que ça n'a pas du tout
péricliter au contraire puisqu'il ya
plus de bénévoles que jamais on est
presque dix mille maintenant que les
politiques sont toujours là et très
actif dans les municipalités où dans les
pouvoirs publics que les artistes je
crois qu'on va en dire un mot et une
tournée dont on a déjà entendu parler
mais parfois quand soirée n'y a pas que
ça il ya aussi des artistes locaux il ya
aussi d'autres à retirer acquis dans
cette tournée
véronique sanson eddy mitchell jean
jacques goldman géniale idée initiale
sardou qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire des
duos des trios sur sa une surprise ça va
passer à la télé ça va passer sur canal
quand 21 10 ans le 21 décembre ce jour
d'ouverture des risques calculés
alors en plus des restos ya les relais
du coeur c'est quoi si les relais du
coeur c'est quelque chose qui continue
au delà de l'action des restaurants du
coeur c'est à dire que quand on dit
d'eux on distribue pendant tout l'hiver
jusqu'au 21 mars et qui on s'est aperçu
qu'en fait les gens nous des comptes à
tous temps les bénévoles que les
bénéficiaires d'ailleurs et que tout
d'un coup brutalement arrêté c'est
dramatique pour moi parce qu'ils
retournent à leur solitude et leur
exclusion et on a considéré que ça
méritait qu'on maintienne des lieux où
ils peuvent venir prendre un café et
puis surtout exposé leurs problèmes
et puis à la loi coluche shaïek irak
oui oui il organise toi tu donnes tu
donnes de 300 francs aux restos du coeur
puisque la moyenne des gens courtois et
des empreintes 1 300 francs restos du
coeur au moment de payer des impôts qui
enlève 150 la femme à culpa juppé a fait
appel comme pas oui il en était désolé
il n'a vu l'autre jour puisqu'il vous
nous a annoncé juste avant la conférence
de presse qu'en fait tu nous verser une
subvention pour sur rtl c'est la chose
que je regrette quand j'étais mines et
j'aurais dû faire passer la loi coluche
il a dit que c'était la première fois
qu'il était ministre mais il semble que
charasse aussi ministre la première fois
comme quoi
mais tout va c'est un scandale quand
même qu'on soit obligé de faire un truc
pareil pour nourrir les gens france en
les scandales mais elle a beaucoup il y
en a beaucoup il ya le fait qu'on soit
dans une société d'où sont exclus de
toutes sortes des milliers de gens quand
même on va vers le 21e siècle et il y en
a plein qui sont complètement jeter
autant chez les bénéficiaires que chez
les bénévoles parce que chez les
bénévoles et des catégories des
catégories sociales à qui on dit
plus besoin de vous ça c'est un scandale
il ya d'autres scandales aujourd'hui
quand je vois que tout le monde
contribue à aider les restaurants du
coeur et que les grands médias comme tf1
ou antenne 2 quand on leur amène le
plateau avec les artistes ne diffuse pas
de spot c'est pas bien c'est pas bien
que l'on va diffuser ces moments là je
vais peut-être avec où ces gars-là c'est
ça c'est encore autre chose mais on
espère que tu verras d'articles vous
souhaite de la communion où on voit tous
les articles en train de répéter qu'ils
avaient fait ça peut on parle de cette
tournée on veut vraiment très bien sûr
tout le monde n'est pas mauvais
d'avoir dix mois
je
d
à
jeanne
on va faire une interview à peine
d'après ce que je crois être connue
c'était quoi
moi j'aime énormément l'isère mai
c'est probablement dans l'est
dans les commentaires politiques plus
rire c'est pas un sketch en particulier
est scellé les chutes etc d'art comme ça
sur des autoroutes dans son bain jusqu'à
ce que tu aimais le mois le padd qu'est
ce que j'aimais pas sympathiques je n'ai
pas et aujourd'hui c'est qu'il mcit fait
le plus rire
c'est peut-être chez moi oui les enfants
ouais mais qui fait le moins et on va
reprendre et ça peut être tout le monde
quand il se prend au sérieux
non j'ai pas de nous on ne sait pas s'il
ya des petites vedettes de la télévision
préférées
je me demande si c'est pas le président
mitterrand c'est celle que tu t'étais
pas les dents blanches dans blanche
s'était coupé les cheveux et qui posent
des questions mais chante maintenant
s'est pas senti la plus grande joie dans
la vie c'était quoi mais je t'ai dis moi
j'aime rire donc à chaque fois vont rire
les joyeuses le plein du point la plus
grande peine c'est vécu simplement
c'était ou
je crois très pas sur un moment la peine
c'est sur votre bureau
ce que tu préfères en toi c'est quoi un
fol pas tu travailles pas de tonnes
c'est pas français et non pas tant parce
que tu détestes en toi vas-y c'est
d'être timide et naïve je t'aime pas là
non non pas trop vraiment fun
non c'est sympa non c'est vrai ça m'a
offert